ps4 exclusive horizons era Dawn's  pre-order bonuses and deluxe edition  have been revealed should you be like  dahling at your dollars early you'll get  the Norma Sheen trapper pack which  includes weapon and outfit modifications  for your protagonist alloy as well as  crafting resources the seventy dollar  digital deluxe edition includes two  resource packs of the codger trader and  the barrack traveller two outfits and  two weapons the car Joe mighty bow and  the Vanek culling bow you'll also get a  digital art book and a ps4 theme if  you're really keen you can also get the  120 dollar collector's edition which  comes with a 9 inch statue at a 48-page  art book you can check out our preview  from our hands-on session with horizon  zero dawn on gamespot  you